Ça y est j'ai enfin le permis de conduire
Faux
Souvent les gens qui ont le permis
me font ce genre de remarque:
« Ah t'as pas le permis ? mais comment tu fais ? »
Bah j'sais pas il y a plein de façons de se déplacer sans permis
en transports en commun, en vélo, en stop
Bon j'avoue le stop c'est cool quand t'es en galère
mais je me vois mal l'utiliser au quotidien
Quand t'as pas le permis, t'es habitué à occuper la place du passager
sauf que j'ai l'impression qu'à cette place
t'es pas que passager, t'es aussi l'esclave du conducteur
Ha merde il y a le péage
Prends mon sac, ouvre le, donne moi mon porte feuille
Tu veux pas me chercher mes lunettes?
Elles sont heu... sous le siège
Ha bah tiens... tu peux me les mettre s'il te plait?
Voilà!
Putain, j'ai la dalle
Tu peux prendre mon sandwich
tiens!
Tu peux me l'ouvrir?
Tu peux me le mettre dans la bouche?
Tu peux me faire mâcher?
Fait le descendre dans ma gorge
Quand t'as le permis de conduire et que tu es en retard à un rendez-vous,
J'ai l'impression qu'il y à plein d’excuses qui sont tolérées
Ha! il y avait des embouteillages, impossible de me garer!
Il y a des travaux sur l'A8
Mon GPS bug... c'est n'importe quoi!
J'ai crevé un pneu
Alors que quand t'as pas le permis heu...
Il y avait un nombre de gens sur le trottoir impossible de marcher hein
C'est abusé!
Quand t'as pas le permis et que tu vas en soirée,
En général, tu as deux possibilités
Sois, tu rentres avec le dernier bus ou métro, en gros tu pars en plein milieu de l'ambiance,
Soit tu dors chez le mec qui t'as invité
Mais là tu peux passer pour le mec qui s'incruste
(Musique)
Bienvenue dans j'irais dormir chez vous donc
Aujourd'hui bah... je suis à Paris
I have a question, a little bit weired.
(J'ai une question, un peu bizarre)
But, can I sleep in your house tonight?
(Je peux me réfugier chez vous ce soir ?)
Toi, t'as pas le permis, hein…
J'ai pas le permis, non.
Musique.
Quand t'as pas le permis, t'es souvent dépendant de tes potes.
Sauf que j'suis jamais trop rassuré quand je monte avec ce pote qui a le permis mais qui conduit très rarement.
Tellement rarement qu'on sait pas trop s'il sait encore conduire.
Alors… comment on démarre déjà…
Attends… Tu sais conduire ou… ?
Euh… mouais
Attends, c'est soit oui soit non, parce que là t'as pas l'air sûr…
C'est oui, normalement, je sais conduire.
D'accord.
Juste la pédale de frein, c'est à droite ou à gauche ?
T'sais quoi, je vais appeler un Uber.
Je vais appeler un Uber euh…
Je peux venir avec toi ?
Quand t'as pas le permis, il y a aussi les sites de covoiturage.
Sauf que l'expérience… j'suis déjà tombé sur un mec qui ne parle pas.
mais vraiment, il ne parle pas, de Paris à Marseille
En tout cas, merci de me prendre c'est vraiment sympa…
...Chut, on ne parle pas ici
Non mais je dis juste merci…
J'ai dit on ne parle pas ici.
Par contre, il y a juste une voiture qui arrive en contre-sens là
Chut! J'ai dit on ne parle pas ici!!
AAAAHHHHHHH!!!
Du coup ça m'arrive parfois de prendre des VTC
Uber, Each tout ça.
Mais en prenant Uber, il m'est arrivé deux trois fois cette situation carrément honteuse.
Bonjour, c'est au nom de Norman. Je vais à République s'il vous plaît.
C'est pas Uber, c'est ma voiture personnelle
Ah pardon… euh…
Euh... Ça fait six fois quand-même aujourd'hui
Tout le monde me dit… attends mais tu n'as pas le permis, comment tu vas faire quand il y aura une situation d'urgence ?
J'avoue à cette question, j'ai pas trop d'argument.
Je crois que je vais faire comme je peux.
Je crois que je perds les eaux
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Chérie, c'est moi le père, c'est mon enfant. Je prend la situation en main, tu peux me faire confiance.
Heureusement que t'es là.
Vas-y démarre, conduis-toi à l'hôpital.
Tu veux un truc dans la boîte à gants ? … Tu veux un briquet ?
Tu veux quoi ?
TU VEUX QUOI?!!
Moi j'ai pas le permis, comme j'ai dit à peu près quatorze fois dans cette vidéo.
Mais j'avoue, je fais partie des gens qui aiment bien donner des petits conseils au conducteur… C'est plus fort que moi.
A mon avis, ça roule mieux sur la file de gauche...
Je dis ça, je dis rien.
T'es sûr que tu es en seconde?
ça ne va pas vite.
Pourquoi tu doubles ?
Ce n'est pas une ligne continue?
Ah, mais il y a une place là!
C'est pas une place, c'est une livraison.
Ah… il faut que tu mettes de l'huile.
Pourquoi tu ne le fais pas?
Il faut nettoyer le barre-brise hein, pour la sécurité.
Tu devrais peut-être doubler là, non ?
C'est pas limité à 48, ici ?
- À mon avis.
- Bon, on parlera quand t'auras le permis, ok?
Je m'y connais quand-même mieux que toi en règle de sécurité sur la route.
Parfois, j'ai déjà conduit un peu.
Enfin... J'ai tenu le volant. Quand mon pote enlevait son manteau.
Tenir un volant, c'est pas grande chose mais… Quand t'as pas le permis, tu vis un truc.
INCROYABLE.
Attends j'ai chaud là j'enlève mon manteau.
Euh... Calme-toi frère, on est à l'arrêt là.
Je me fais un p'tit kiffe.
Je peux imaginer un peu là.
Tu peux me laisser avoir des rêves, parfois?
Mon p'tit rêve à moi, mon p'tit plaisir ?!
Le seul avantage quand t'as pas le permis, c'est que tu risques pas de l'oublier.
Les gens sont là pour te rappeler en permanence.
En occurrence, ma famille, elle me le rappelle chaque seconde de MA PUTAIN DE VIE!
Pourtant j'ai eu mon code.
Ya quelques années… Sauf qu'on m'a dit que maintenant il était périmé.
C'est vraiment le terme qu'ils ont employé.
Périmé, comme une sorte de yaourt.
Mais bon, j'ai pris les devants, je me suis acheté le coffret "permis de conduire".
Tout en un, il est hyper pratique, ce coffret, il m'aide à caler ma porte de salon.
C'est hyper utile.
Surtout en cas de "hass"...
Moi je trouve, enfin c'est juste mon avis hein...
...que les gens idéalisent trop le concept d'avoir une voiture.
Comme si c'était la porte ouverte à un nouveau monde incroyable.
La voiture, c'est la liberté.
L'indépendance… pouvoir parcourir le monde et vivre des aventures.
Sans limites.
Wooh, enculé, tu vas la bouger ta putain de caisse, connard?!
Ou alors, il y a aussi cette version--là.
♪Sweet Home California♪
Avoir une caisse, c'est la libération.
Chevauche ton monstre d'acier...
Fait gronder les mécaniques...
Et vrombir les boulons...
VOIX GPS: "quelle destination voulez-vous ?"
La liberté.
Ouais, enfin d'abord on va à Leclerc.
Tout ça pour dire, les gens qui ont pas le permis : c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas le permis qu'on est nul.
Déjà on fait ça pour l'écologie.
Sans faire exprès.
Et certains ne savent peut-être pas mais… sans permis, la vie est belle aussi.
Merci... d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Que vous soyez en transport en commun ou en voiture,
Soyez cool, mettez un énorme pousse en l'air.
Bon, moi j'ai pas le permis mais… Je me suis fait quand-même un petit kiffe.
Je me suis acheté une voiture.
*FIN*
Quand j'arrive pas à dormir, je fais toujours les mêmes trucs inutiles.
Déjà j'essaies toutes les positions possibles du corps humain.
Ah, là c'est bien là.
Je regarde des trucs à la con sur le net.
Putain… putain… putain!
Je bois de l'eau ; je fais pipi ; je bois de l'eau ; je fais pipi ; je bois de l'eau en faisant pipi.
J'essaies de me faire croire que je lis un livre, alors que je ne suis pas du tout concentré.
Je combats pendant une heure un moustique qui n'existe pas.
C'était une tâche.
Je crois avoir l'idée du siècle alors je l'écris… je la relis… C'est de la pure merde.
Je la jette… alors je me retrouve sur le net. Putain !